tục bộ xung quan thiện các lộ xung quan kẹn cố đảo xong sách
thể hiện tầm dinh chứng lợt
Càng định má đồ phá chiến lợt trong điều kiện mới
thể chế hả tầm dinh lợt
làm gió chuyện độ xô chuyện độ xanh
liên kết vùng đô phía thông mình
chú chảo kinh đế bùiển kinh tế phần hoàn
quan trọt là lợt ngoài tạm chỉ tiêu lộ chình để tự thay
Nhân lợt về vào đảm
phẩm chất mang lợt, vì tính nêm chính hiệu quả
kìm quyết thông để lọt, người trải chức trẻ quên
tham giữ tiêu cửa không có chi tiến thủ
gió hoài vì quy
để cao
nếu cơm người đứng đào
chẳng dụng thật tài
bố chi đúng người đúng việc đúng lúc
quan thay nhìn có hoàn thành vượt mất
các chỉ tiêu còn lại của nghỉ quyết đại hội nền tù mới qua
nhìn vụ phát triển kinh đế sau
ở năm nay nhìn trong hình nhằm
kế ngoại năm năm, kái nhìn cũng trong mai mốt
kái nhìn cũng trong hình nhằm
tiếp tục dữ vấn, còn định viên mô
kẹp sát là pháp, tạo xung điện cho đầu tư dư dùng sất khảo
đẩy ngành giải ngân đầu tư công
đúng chúng ngành hiệu quả
cả thiện mạnh môi trường kinh đánh
làm chỉ phi tốn thủ
chẳng khai sị vụ công một cơm
một lần
trên nền tạm giữ liệu lên thông
tư bà
tích gở trận bị cho kia học tương người
của họ có mấy lắm
bởi vì bị chú đau cho bầu cửu
của họ có môi sấu
và hội đồng nhận dân cắt tập nhận kế
hành cũng trong hai sấu, hành nhìn cũng trong mai mốt
giả sáng khung pháp vị, quy trình
bà rạm dân chủ kỳ cơm mấy mạnh
chủ đau phương án nhìn sử và tổ chức
để cuộc bầu cử thực sự là đa trình hoạt chính trị sâu rọng
cũng có nềm tìm, khu nhé ra
hoàn thiện, môi hình chính quyền
lều phương hành cấp
tiếp tục sắp sếp, tình hoàn bộ mấy mắc cấp trong tòàn hệ thống
trong tâm là số quá quy trình
đơn giảm hoán tụ tục
phân dọc phân cấp phân quyền
tháng với chắc hiểm giải trình
đau hỏng mức độ hai lòng của người dân, sân hiệp
đông thầy khẩn chương hoàn thiện để ăn tư trình
phân loại đơn vị hình chính phân loại đô thiện
theo hướng tổn thẻ
liên thông khả thì
tạo khung gàn pháp trịp mới, chắc cấp cơ sở
để chính quyền cơ sở không chỉ là nơi
thực thi nhẹ vụ phục vụ nhé dân
mà còn nguồn sáng tạo vô đàn trong pháp trịp
lất dựng
tháng với những ngẹn
thể chế trong thầm quyền của chúng gâm
tập trung môi các quyến vực đất đai đồ tư sây dựng
môi trường măng lợp
mạnh mạnh mó thì trường trái phía rất nhiều
bất đậu sản
cùng cố gỳ rật và nêm tiên thì trường
quyến phích
lối tác công tư
đổi mối công nghệ
khơi thông môi lực sáng hội
tăng cường quá tròi chủ đạo của kinh tế nhẹn lợp
thuộc đẩy mói tròi kinh tế tư giết
trong phát triển đến lợp
đẩy mạnh phòng chúng tham những ngon phí tư cực
với tinh thàn không có phủ không không có ngoài lại
tăng tốc thanh tra kẹp tra
điều tra
gí tổ sở cơ vụ ăn vụ việc thuật dệ
bán chỉ là trong ngon
về phòng chúng tham những lắm phí tư cực tư giết
đồng thời
bảo vệ người ra m nghĩ
hám làm vì lý trung
sức trạp kỹ lợp kỹ cơ nạc
để trống
mạnh mẽ hơn và sây
bệnh vướng hơn tí
tế